religion is more than belief its power
and its influence and that influence
affects all of us every day regardless
of your own belief despite the enormous
influence of religion on the world today
we hold them to a different standard of
scrutiny and accountability than any
other sector of our society for example
if there were an ulti national
organization government or corporation
today that said no female could be a
leadership board not one woman could
have decision-making authority not one
woman could handle any financial matter
we'd have outrage there'd be sanctions
and yet this is a common practice in
almost every world religion today we
accept things in our religious lives
that we do not accept in our secular
lives and I know this because I've been
doing it for three decades I was the
type of girl that fought every form of
gender discrimination growing up I
played pickup basketball games with the
boys and inserted myself I said I was
going to be the first female president
of the United States I have been
fighting for the Equal Rights Amendment
which has been dead for 40 years I'm the
first woman in both sides of my family
to ever work outside the home and ever
receive a higher education I never
accepted being excluded because I was a
woman except in my religion throughout
all of that time I was a part of a very
patriarchal Orthodox Mormon religion I
grew up in an enormous ly traditional
family I have eight siblings a
stay-at-home mother my father's actually
a religious leader in the community and
I grew up in a world believing that my
Worth and my standing was in keeping
these rules that I've ever known my
whole life you get married a virgin you
never drink alcohol you don't smoke you
always do serve
yes you're a good kid some of the rules
we had were strict but you followed the
rules because you loved the people and
you loved the religion and you believed
we everything about Mormonism determined
what you would I wore who you dated who
you married it determined what underwear
we wore yeah I was the kind of religious
where everyone I know donated ten
percent of everything they earned to the
church including myself from paper
routes and babysitting I donated ten
percent I was the kind of religious
where I heard parents tell children when
they're leaving on a two-year
proselyting miss admission that they
would rather have them die and return
home without honor having sinned I was
the type and the kind of religious where
kids kill themselves every single year
because they're terrified of coming out
to our community as gay but it was also
the kind of religious where didn't
matter where in the world I lived I had
friendship instantaneous mutual aid this
is where I felt safe this is certainty
and clarity about life I had help
raising my little daughter so that's why
I accepted without question but only men
can lead and I accepted without question
that women can have the spiritual
authority of God on the earth which we
call the priesthood and I allow
discrepancies between men and women in
operating budgets disciplinary councils
in decision-making capacities and I gave
my religion a free pass because I loved
it until I stopped and I realized that I
had been allowing myself to be treated
as the support staff to the real work of
men and I faced this contradiction in
myself and I joined with other activists
in my community we've been working very
very very hard for the last decade and
more the first thing we did was raise
consciousness you can't change what you
can't see
we started podcasting blogging writing
articles we I created lists of hundreds
of ways that men and women are an equal
in our community the next thing we did
was build advocacy organizations we
tried to do things that were
uncomfortable
horrible like wearing pants to church
and trying to attend all-male meetings
these seem like simple things but to us
the organizers they were enormous ly
costly we lost relationships we lost
jobs we got hate mail on a daily basis
we were attacked in social media and
national press we received death threats
we lost standing in our community we got
some of us got excommunicated most of us
got put in front of a Disciplinary
Council and we were ejected from the
communities that we loved because we
wanted to make them better because we
believed that they could be and I began
to expect this reaction from my own
people I know what it feels like when
you feel like someone's trying to change
you or or criticize you but what utter
ly shocked me was throughout all of this
work I received equal measures of
vitriol from the secular left the same
vehement as the religious right and what
my secular friends didn't realize was
that this religious hostility these
phrases of oh all religious people are
crazy or stupid don't pay attention to
religion they're going to be homophobic
and sexist what they didn't understand
was it that type of hostility did not
fight religious extremism it read
religious extremism those arguments
don't work and I know because I remember
someone telling me that I was stupid for
being Mormon and what it caused me to do
is defend myself and my people and
everything we believed in because we're
not stupid
so criticism and hostility doesn't work
and I didn't listen to these arguments
when I hear these arguments I still
continue to Bristol because I have
family and friends these are my people
and I'm the first to defend them but the
struggle is real how do we respect
someone's religious beliefs while still
holding them accountable for the harm or
damage that those beliefs may cause
others it's a tough question
I still don't have a perfect answer my
parents and I have been walking on this
tightrope for the last decade
they're intelligent people they're
lovely people and let me try to help you
understand their perspective in
Mormonism we believe that after you die
if you keep all the rules and you follow
all the rituals you can be together as a
family again and to my parents me doing
something as simple as having a
sleeveless top right now showing my
shoulders that makes me unworthy I won't
be with my family in the eternities but
even more I had a brother died in a
tragic accident at fifteen and something
as simple as this means we won't be
together as a family and to my parents
they cannot understand why something as
simple as fashion or women's rights
would prevent me from seeing my brother
again and that's the mindset that we're
dealing with and criticism does not
change that and so my parents and I have
been walking this tightrope explaining
our sides respecting one another but
actually invalidating each other's very
basic beliefs by the way we live our
lives and it's been difficult the way
that we've been able to do that is to
get past those defensive shells and
really see that soft inside of unbelief
and belief and try to respect each other
while still holding boundaries clear the
other thing that the secular left and
the atheists and the Orthodox and the
religious right what they all don't
understand was why even care about
religious activism I cannot tell you the
hundreds of people who have said if you
don't like religion just leave why would
you try to change it because what is
taught on the Sabbath leaks into our
politics our health policy violence
around the world it leaks into education
military fiscal decision making these
laws get legally and culturally codified
in fact my own religion has had an
enormous effect on this nation for
example during prop 8 my church raised
over 22 million dollars to fight
same-sex marriage in California 40 years
ago political historians will say that
if it wasn't for the Mormon opposition
to the equal rights of men
we'd have an Equal Rights Amendment in
our Constitution today how many lives
did that affect and we can spend time
fighting every single one of these
little tiny laws and rules or we can ask
ourselves why is gender inequality the
default around the world why is that the
assumption because religion doesn't just
create the roots of morality
it creates the seeds of normality
religions can liberate or subjugate they
can empower or exploit they can comfort
or destroy and the people that tip the
scales over to the ethical and the moral
are often not those in charge
religions can't be dismissed or ignored
we need to take them seriously but it's
not easy to influence a religion like we
just talked about it I'll tell you what
my people have done my groups are small
there's hundreds of us but we've impact
had huge impact
right now women's pictures are hanging
in the halls next to men for the first
time women are now allowed to pray in
our church wine meetings and they never
were before in the general conferences
as of last week in a historic move three
women were invited down to three
leadership boards that oversee the
entire church we've seen perceptual
shifts in the Mormon community that
allow for talk of gender inequality
we've opened up space regardless of
being despised for more conservative
women to step in and make real changes
and the words women and the priesthood
can now be uttered in the same sentence
I never had that my daughter and my
nieces are inheriting a religion that I
never had that's more equal we've had an
effect
it wasn't easy standing in those lines
trying to get into those male meetings
there were hundreds of us and one by one
we got to the door we were told I'm
sorry this meeting is just for men and
we had to step back and watch men get
into the meeting as young as twelve year
escorted and walked past us as we all
stood in line but not one woman in that
line will forget that day and not one
little boy that walked past us will
forget that day if we were a
multinational corporation or a
government and that had happened there
would be outrage but we're just a
religion we're all just part of
religions we can't keep looking at
religion that way because it doesn't
only affect me it affects my daughter
and all of your daughters and what
opportunities they have what they can
wear who they can love and marry if they
have access to reproductive health care
we need to reclaim morality in a secular
context that creates ethical scrutiny
and accountability for religions all
around the world but we need to do it in
a respectful way that breeds cooperation
and not extremism and we can do it
through unag Nora Belasco every standing
up for gender equality it's time that
half of the world's population had voice
and equality within our world's
religions churches synagogues mosques
and shrines around the world I'm working
on my people what are you doing for
yours
you